Film Courage: How do you
attract name talent to a movie?
Ramfis Myrthil, Film Producer, Film Consultant
and Speaker: I think a lot of it is just being
genuine. At the end of the day whether it's film
or not film or whatever position it's just being
authentic and genuine because people could
sense the BS if you're just trying to sell
them or whatever so I always come from a place
of authenticity and telling them why I want to
work with them whether it's in an email or social
media or whatever the case is but what I've done
is that I've figured out where a certain actor
or actress is going to be that I may want to
work with so maybe they have a film Premiere at a
festival or let's say I will attend a screening a
private screening that's happening I'll track
screenings so for for example I'm a member of
BAFTA and now it's BAFTA I think America so I can
go to BAFTA the screenings in New York LA and the
UK so if there's a particular talent that I want
to work with a lot of times they'll end up going
to a q a at BAFTA and I've approached numerous
actors that way anywhere from Orlando Orlando
Bloom to Mark Ruffalo to individuals that and it's
not necessarily easy to get in front of them but
I look for a window after the Q a usually I try to
go actually as soon as it ends because sometimes
they just run out and I'll just pull them to the
side if they have a rep or don't have a rep there
if they have their rep there it's a little
bit more difficult because their rep will try
to shut it down but if their rep is not there
usually their publicist is there if their reps
aren't there but I go right to the point I talk
about their past movies what they've done why I
them and that I want to work with them and can I
contact them directly and I want to say in terms
of Mark Ruffalo I was at a screening for dark
Waters in New York and he just hung out he just
hung out the entire time afterwards which I was
really shocked and he talked to everyone in super
kind and I told him that at the end I'm I can't
believe you talked to everybody and stayed and
and he asked me a little bit about who I was
and what I was making what I was doing and
and I pretty much answered those questions and
without even asking he had offered me his email
address which was insane I mean did I end up
getting him for the project that I mentioned to
him no it didn't happen but but I believe it was
authentic and genuine the conversation which is
why he gave me the time of the day and entertained
it so and the same thing happened with Orlando
Bloom I went to a screening of Carnival circus
in New York and he was there and he was coming
out one of my favorite movies is Kingdom of
Heaven another Ridley Scott film told release
got the same thing I love kingdom of heaven
and I told Orlando Bloom how I love that and
and Troy and all the other things that he's
done and and he's oh yeah that's great man
we could find he's probably typical he hears
oh I want to work with you and he's yeah we
should find something work on just passing
through I said actually I have something
and I just went right into my pitch and he was
Wow taken back and he flagged over his assistant
assistant came over and we exchanged info and we
started conversation did it manifest into anything
no probably the rate we offered him was too low
and maybe he wasn't impressed with the filmmaker
and the the thing that was probably logically true
is because he probably had a lot of you didn't
have availability he was probably booked out I ran
into Frank Grillo one time in in West Hollywood
and I happened to be wearing a purge t-shirt so I
saw him I flagged him down I'm Frank how and he's
wait a second you're wearing the shirt and it's
just it all aligned right place right time and
I told him how I knew James and he loves James
and we're he's telling me about another movie
that he did with James and Naomi Watts and we're
having a conversation and then I'm dude I tried
to work with you multiple times I've tried to go
through your agency your rap that the creative
artist agency and they can be very difficult
and I listed his agents and his manager I have
a very good memory and so he knew I was serious
and did you ever read the script he never heard
of it oh that's not a surprise I've heard this
story many times how talent doesn't get material
and and then I talked about his production partner
he works with Joe Carnahan a lot and I mentioned
that I'm very close with his publicist and and
I was invited to a screening of a film that he
had coming out and I couldn't get into LA for that
reason whenever it happened so he's dude just why
don't you just contact me directly going forward
that's what he said I'm oh that's a great idea I'd
love that and he gave me his number and his email
and and I just stayed in touch I followed up with
him followed up with him about the project
that I wanted him to work on and ultimately
he just told me that he wasn't available and to
keep him in mind for whatever else to reach out
and it just didn't work out so sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't in terms of this thing but
I have a very aggressive approach and I
want to get in front of people because
they'll see the passion I feel and
that this person is 100 legit on board
and that I appreciate the film process and the
study and I'm not just a fan I'm not just saying
I want to work with them I have legitimate reasons
and I'm able to back it up and I make sure that
when I share whatever information about working
with them I kind of just tee it up This is the
project this is when we're looking to shoot this
is the budget this is we have the money we don't
have the money these are the pieces this is why
we want you on it how can we make it work straight
to the point so they know I'm serious I'm not
hesitating and I'm doing it in a concise manner
I don't necessarily rehearse it but in the
beginning probably I did I've gotten to a point
where I'm just comfortable it's a conversation and
these are how projects happen and come together so
so I've done that also done the social media
thing where maybe reaching out we I've done
it once on Instagram where it has worked there
was a foreign project I was putting together and
it's a very famous I want to say Italian
actress I didn't necessarily do it but I
had someone on the team reach out and she read
the material and she was interested it it didn't
work out because we didn't get all the money
to make it happen but that happened one time
other times one of the things that I do
is that I did a film with Mercedes rule
and it was a short back back way back when and one
of the actors had a really good relationship with
her had worked with her before and we basically
just went through her directly we never dealt
with her agents or reps and she came on board so
one idea that I always say is you get one you get
all their friends so that's a strategy that I
use and they want to work with their friends so
that's one way just getting a list from them
who do who do you have a relationship with
who would be who you've been trying to work with
sometimes it's going through the agent directly
I do really well in Europe the agents are a
little bit more I want to say flexible so if
the actor or actress has rep in the U.S and in
Europe especially if it's European project I'm
going to go through their reps over there I've
been able to somewhat attach talent that way
it doesn't always work especially if the US
agent is not friendly then they'll shut it
down sometimes that works and then obviously
using a casting director that's been one way
a lot of the times if I don't have the bandwidth
or the energy or I just can't figure out how to
get in front of a certain actor or actors we'll
just use that and it's a lot of work to honestly
there was a there was a project I really wanted to
get Jamie Foxx involved in and I think the night
before there was a screening happening in LA I
found out on a Friday night a friend of mine told
me about the screening and I was trying to figure
out how the hell the fly from New York to LA to
get there in time to get I couldn't find a flight
to match it and the flights were very expensive
and I was oh man I really want to make it so it
just didn't work out so there's times that where
it just doesn't work and it's probably it'll be
very hard to get in front of him I've done that
with he just Alba one time where I was actually
at his party at Sundance and his producing partner
was going to introduce us but when he had wrapped
up he DJs a lot he was wrapping up his DJ set his
security detail just surrounded him because there
were a lot of people there and I guess he didn't
want to talk to anyone and he just voted so
the producing partner couldn't introduce me
so I had gone down to Art Basil in Miami and
I knew he was going to be there at this club
DJing and I went to the club and I waited for
him to come and he came out of course but it's
really dark it's loud and there's a million
bodies in front of you and I just couldn't
get through I legit couldn't get through and I
was just so pissed I'm I can't I can't believe
I did all this to get through in front of him
can't even talk to him and even if I did a part
of me is it probably wouldn't work because he's
DJing and it's so loud and he's not gonna stop
DJing to talk to me so I thought out how it
could work some sometimes it works out where
there's a moment where they're by themselves or
whatever and you get that moment to talk to them
and other times it's just impossible because
security around them or it's a loud venue
but I would say my success rate is pretty high
because again I'm very polished and buttoned up
when I approach an actor or actress and it's not
as a fan I have an agenda I have proof of whatever
I'm talking about I make sure it's in a place
that it has some type of element that's exciting
whether it's an exciting writer or director or
both or a production company or producer or I
have money I'm not going to come with a bad script
with nothing because it just doesn't make sense so
just along the way I've just met a lot of great
talent just being at festivals just walking in
Santa Monica one day I'm walking and I oh man
it's Craig Robinson and then I walk over I'm wait
are you Crag you look Craig is yeah dude I said
I'd love to work on something with you and he's
oh cool we should find something to work on and
I'm pitching him and I'm dude give me your number
then he's okay gives me his number and his email
then we started a friendship a relationship so
I just reached out to Craig I brought in projects
and unfortunately it just didn't hit he wasn't
interested in it or wasn't what he wanted to make
and do so just and we just said hey we'll find
something one day eventually but I have that open
lane where I don't have to go through his wraps or
whatever or be blocked so I've done that quite a
bit with a few actors and developed relationships
with and it's out of the box most people aren't
thinking they might be intimidated or they don't
know how what to say and maybe in the beginning I
would have been really nervous but I've practiced
so many times doing Toastmasters and Toastmasters
is a not-for-profit group that helps with public
speaking so I've practiced my public speaking
so many times in a group in front of one person
some people good one-on-one and they could
talk one-on-one and some people are good at
talking to a group I've practiced both just
to be able to because I believe that it's my
responsibility to be the best producer I can so
that's investing in myself this has doesn't do
it film but taking classes where I can be
the best me so I can show up the best way
and that's really helped me to be able to do
these things and figure things out so that's
one of the ways that I find and attract Talent
or work with talent but I've done everything
under the sun as you can see to work with Talent
do you adjust your approach based on New York LA
Europe is there is there an LA approach that
would not work in New York and vice versa
the thing is that I try just to feed into how I
would do it I don't look at the fact that I'm in
New York or LA because what I've been told by
my colleagues in LA is that it's inappropriate
don't do it you could be shamed for it or whatever
and I've seen it being in an LA party or whatever
there'll be some cool person and people just
pretend that they're not there but they know
they're there and it's it's weird what I mean oh
it's it looks it belittles you if you go and talk
to them and no I'm just gonna go in it doesn't
matter and and I and I use my personality that's
where I feel comfortable in myself whether they
say they don't want to talk to me or not they
could just say no I don't want to talk to you
I'm not interested I want to say most actors that
I've met and approached I just come coming really
direct hey this is my name this is what I do want
to work with you love your work what you've done
this is the project how can we do this and they'll
say maybe contact their reps I'll deflect I did
that with Eddie Redmayne I ran into him right
after he when he was nominated I think and he
didn't want to give me his direct info so he said
if you really want to contact me you don't want
to deal with my reps I don't want to deal with my
agent contact my manager and my manager responds
don't worry about it and that's what I did so
it's their level of comfort if they don't
want to give me their email or phone number
then that's fine what's the best way to contact
you so yeah does rejection challenge you in the
beginning I think rejection was very challenging
but the thing is that people say no for so many
reasons and sometimes it's no because they woke
up on the wrong side of the bed and sometimes
it's just legitimately they're not interested so
because I've rejected projects or not necessarily
people but things and it just doesn't align or the
timing's off or I was speaking with a colleague of
mine yesterday that won an Oscar last year and
he was nominated for another Oscar in another
movie he's done two really big movies and he
has two other really big movies coming out and
and everyone's going after him right now and he's
listen I want to do projects where I collaborate
with people I don't want to just do jobs and
the thing is that I can't do everything and a
lot of times I turn down really big paychecks
or opportunities or getting offered an overall
deal and it doesn't make sense but this is my
process and I want to spend time with my family
I want to do this I need to take two months off
after this movie comes out the end of this year
and just hearing that it's okay cool he's
rejecting really big his agents he's rejecting big
money opportunities he's rejecting A-list people
on the level of Spielberg and it wasn't Spielberg
but that level and it's not because he's rejecting
them it's just that it just doesn't fit with what
he's doing right now and he wants to be the best
him when he does a project so when I go to someone
and Pitch them and they reject me I don't make
up a story I look it for what it is what it is
is that they said no and that was it they're
not rejecting Ramfis the individual they're not
rejecting even the project they just maybe they
just don't have the capacity or maybe they're
dealing with a sick child or a sick family member
there's so many things that could be going and I
read this book called The Four Agreements [author
Don Miguel Ruiz] and one of the rules in The Four
Agreements is don't take anything personal so I've
embodied that with my day-to-day just not to take
things personal Ramfis do you have a project for
almost everyone's if we saw a b or c walking down
the street somewhere in Hollywood Santa Monica
would you be oh so and so I love your work and
their work inside and out their IMDb credits
it's 50 50. half the times I have something
that'll fit because I fluctuate with multiple
projects I have a slate of different genres
so I would say fifty percent of the time I
have something that would be great for them
to do the other fifty percent of the time I
don't but when I don't have something if I
ran into Jennifer Aniston for example I don't
have anything that would be for her per se but
it would be good to have that in the back pocket
if I have a project that makes sense so I'll give
you a real story of what happened I was at
Sundance Film Festival this was 2018 and I
was going to a party that Christine Vachon was
throwing from Killer Films really dear friend
and I was going in to the party but at Sundance
you have to be on a list it's very strict and the
group in front of me couldn't get in because they
weren't on the list the group behind me or the guy
behind me so the guy in front of me couldn't get
in and the girls behind me couldn't because they
weren't on the list but the guy in front of me we
hit it off so well and I went into this party and
it was for the film that they had done with
Dominic West and Keira Knightley they were there
I didn't approach them because they were in
this area and there was a lot of security and it
probably just didn't look right or good if I broke
that line so I didn't do that so I just engaged
with Christine and the people at Killer Films and
I went and spoke with other individuals that were
there so I met a guy that was a talent I think he
was a talent agent became talent manager or maybe
he was a talent manager he was a talent manager
and then I met with another guy that's a financier
they went later on to finance
parasite which was really cool
and we just hit it off so well so I stayed
in touch with these two they both lived in LA
and then when I wrapped up at Sundance I went to
LA I usually spend a month in LA afterwards just
doing all my follow-ups with people I've met and
then the guy that was in front of me that couldn't
get in I met with him and he told me about what he
was doing he's Canadian he's between Canada and LA
and he told me that he would send me
some of the projects He was involved
with so he'd sent me one project in particular
that I read I found it really interesting and
I I was telling him just giving a a report of who
I've met in the relationships because sometimes
the the access that I have can fit so I told him
that I met this talent manager in the party that
he couldn't get in that I got into and the talent
manager they represent Billy Bob Thornton so he's
oh my God I have that project you read really
would be great to direct and what I was told
was that Billy was looking for stuff to direct as
well so I was able to set up the relationship and
and then they had the money in the bank they were
able to make an offer for ability to direct the
film so I had all the pieces to basically
put it together and he said if I could make
this happen I'd come on as a capital P producer
I'd be involved and I went to the manager and
I told him exactly what happened and he said
send me the material I read it and I sent him
the offer as well so he knows that there was
actual money and it was a significant offer
and then he gave the script to Billy Bob Thornton
and what ended up happening was that Billy didn't
connect with the material he said he passed it
wasn't for him but in a perfect world Billy would
have said yes he would have directed the film
the financing came through this guy that I met
online and the script and it all comes as one
so with that said when you act when you ask me
in terms of Talent sometimes it's I'll get the
right pieces to put it together to activate it
so I always think about that I have six thousand
phone numbers in my phone I don't always think of
everything in all the pieces but there's a way
for me to make it work if that makes sense so
yeah I mean I would still approach the talent and
tell them XYZ and I'd love to find something to
work with them on and it's really depends when
they're on that level of DiCaprio or Jennifer
Aniston and Vin Diesel it's really hard
to get in front of the 101 because they're
always around somebody and it's going to be very
difficult to get Leonardo DiCaprio's phone number
but it's not impossible I've seen him at
can if I really wanted to get in front of
him there's a way but it would be very difficult
to navigate it but I would still take the shot.